a couple of days ago I had a chat with
an actor called Brent state
if there's a Sci-Fi show that you like
the chances are he appeared in it at
some point
so please enjoy the chat and enjoy a
couple of Clips first and see if you can
spot uh Brent
I take it your Colonel O'Neil
Samantha Carter reporting sir
but of course you go by Sam
you have to worry major I played with
dolls when I was a kid
GI Joe oh Major Matt Mason oh who made
you Matt Mason astronaut doll do you
have that cool little backpack that made
him fly let's get started Colonel thank
you
for those of you on your first trip
through the gate you should be prepared
for what to expect I practically
memorized your report from the first
mission I'd like to think I've been
preparing for this all my life
I think what the colonel is saying is
have you ever pulled out of a simulated
bombing run in an F-16 at eight plus G's
yes
well it's way worse than it by the time
you get to the other side you're frozen
stiff like you've just been through a
blizzard naked that's the result of the
compression your molecules undergo
during the millisecond required for
reconstitution oh here we go what do you
think it's possible for the Harvard is
of the Abyss yes
I understand
but then I understood all along
Montreal has its rocket mystery has its
cruises
we're back in the art of the past is
John Beebe
Precision accuracy more than compensate
for slowness of foot
the only player
[Music]
hey brother how are you doing good good
right everything technical issues so but
we sold them yeah so first of all I just
want to say thank you so much for giving
me your time I know you're a busy guy
and uh it's um it's really nice to be I
know that a lot of people are watching
my channel love Stargates they're going
to absolutely go crazy
you're on here and having a chat with us
about some of the things you've done
over the last
few years
how long have you actually been in the
acting how long I've been doing this uh
I've already
three four 44 years I think I think I
start if I add it up correctly I'm 64.20
yeah about that
I think I started I went to I went to
theater school and I was just turning
eight I was 18 when I went to theater
school I think 19 and then I got out of
there and I went to Stratford for three
seasons in Ontario Stratford on Avon and
Ontario
I did my uh I did an apprenticeship
there and then stayed for a couple
Seasons after that
yeah so that's where I started Stratford
for people who don't know what's wrong
what's the probably the I think it's the
largest
um
Shakespearean theater in North America
so I think the only the one in England
is bigger so it's quite a large Theater
Company a lot of the good actors come
through there
I worked with there and uh
um Eric McCormick and
David Elliott
I think he's still David Elliott he was
David Smith before but he's he's uh he
was on JAG do you remember that show
James I remember
David Elliott Smith David Elliott I
Can't his change his name David Elliott
but yeah I loved him in that show yeah
he's a good actor that was it's a clever
show
um I know you've appeared in loads and
loads of sci-fi over the years and a lot
of the guys that watch this channel
that's what they do to relax you know
they chill out they watch Sci-Fi yeah
yeah but what do you do when you want to
escape reality and you want to do you
know you want to turn your brain off I I
watch some sci-fi but mostly I like um
uh like Game of Thrones and uh I just
finished going through Justified
remember Justified commit the elephant
I've just started watching that again oh
I see it on Disney recently yeah
um Walton Walton Goggins is that it or
yeah you got a strange person awesome
actor man
he plays a brilliant villain and
everything he um was in he played like a
Nazi he played a very similar character
in the Predators movie they did a few
years ago
I heard they're coming back for another
uh another season they are getting a
Revival which is yeah at the moment
forward to it so yeah when was that Game
of Thrones you know of course uh what
else I like I really like the um
what's it called now darn it it's uh the
last Kingdom
do you ever see that I've not watched
that actually really good yeah it's
really good so I like those I like this
I like the Viking stuff and yeah a lot
of people period pieces
but I do watch Sci-Fi too yeah well I
was watching some British period pieces
and then I can imagine you sitting there
watching thingy happy whatever it's
called yeah I love I love uh I love the
British shows I love them yeah well
coming from your acting background I can
kind of understand that it would yeah
you know they're acting so good
that's why we do the best villains we
know we act properly over here we do
everything properly
so I mean your IMDb because I've now had
to record this on the phone I can't look
at
um you can remember you can remember
some of the projects you've done oh yeah
I remember some of them some of them
they change the names as you go along so
you people say oh I saw you in this I'll
go oh I just don't remember that and
then they've just changed the name of it
they do that on occasion we get a lot of
that over here actually it's like films
like um The Longest Yard for Burt
Reynolds yeah and they've they came over
here and they were like oh we've just we
just got rid of yards and we've switched
to the decimal systems they went oh well
people won't understand what that means
and we're like
yeah it's one of my favorite shows I
ever did was mystery Alaska
with Russell Crowe
um yeah Russell Crowe
Hank is area
um Burt Reynolds
um colomini
oh I love him too he's great it was a
real thrill to work I met him
he loves to tell you stories and of
course I loved Deliverance a lot that
was I that was my favorite movie growing
up I just I loved it so I had a lot of
conversations about that movie with him
and I don't remember that
um like murderer movie it's about a it's
about a team of hockey players are up
way up north in Alaska and they end up
playing a pond hockey game against the
New York Rangers
so I have seen that yeah it was called
something different I think I'll Google
it later and then put a little character
named Holt who's uh one of the
goaltenders
okay yeah it's fun I do love hockey
obviously you're Canadian so you love
hockey oh yeah I grew up playing hockey
every yeah who do you follow
what's that who do I follow
well I'm a Manitoba boy so I have to
follow the Jets right because Winnipeg
Jets
so I would follow them yeah I was uh I I
enjoyed the playoffs this year Vegas won
I was that was quite exciting
but yeah so I'm not I'm not a Vancouver
fan though I live in Vancouver I'm a
jazzer I was I was kind of always a Jets
fan and they kind of weren't in the lead
for a long time and then when they came
back
it was uh yeah so everybody jumped ship
of whatever team you were hoping for I
was a Canuck fan and then I went back to
Winnipeg so yeah I was in New York last
year and we went to see a hockey game we
saw the Giants versus I want to say it
was the maple leaf sort of can't
remember that hey police probably and uh
New York Rangers I was the Rangers
so yes yeah you're right um I should
have remembered that because I've got a
Rangers hat next I thought oh I've got
to support the the local team but yeah
okay and you thought there was um I
think they changed the rules a couple of
years ago you probably understand this
better than I do but they'd like tried
to take out a lot of the fights but the
game yeah
but it's an American thing as well
there's like it was just constant
adverts it felt like but it was a live
game I was like just please
um but no I loved it I'm being in
Madison Square Garden I was wicked fine
yeah that was amazing and but sort of
what projects then other than what we
mentioned if you don't know these
because I know like you're in The
X-Files yeah I did a few of those did
Highlander a few couple of Highlanders
um there's what else sci-fi oh Outer
Limits a couple of those yeah I think
everybody's been in the outer limits
everybody I think everybody's been in it
yeah yeah that was a fun one uh what
else you know Stargate Stargate Atlantis
Andromeda
um
we're definitely going to talk about
those in a minute yeah okay and being
the Stargate but what what is there any
project sort of thing that jump out that
really
we shot three three months on that in
Canmore Alberta and uh so we got we got
a pretty good uh pretty tight I'm still
friends with those guys you know a lot
of them Kevin Durant uh Scott Grimes
Russell Crow uh and all those guys yeah
uh
it's called crimes he's a brilliant
actor as well yeah he's wonderful
popping up all over the place he's got a
show on right now uh what's that thing
he's doing the the Sci-Fi thing it's
kind of the Orville yes yeah yeah
he's doing another thing with I think
he's going to appear in Ted as well the
new TV version of Ted oh are they doing
today
who is he is he gonna be the guy the
main guy yeah the main guy I believe so
um so I I think that'll be great he was
always my favorite character in that
it's just one of those actors you just
can't help but like yeah he's he's a
good actor there's a scene in the awful
where he plays a practical joke and
there's there's a robot that's like uh
you know a motionless robot character I
don't know if you've seen much of it
yeah yeah he's doing place a practical
joke on him he sticks a load of Mr
Potato Head bits on his on this guy's
head
um and he sort of goes that's a
practical joke so uh the robot was I I
I'm trying to understand comedy so he
plays a practical joke back on Scott
grimes's character and cuts his leg off
in his sleep
he wakes up in one leg you know that's
not a practical joke you just remembered
me that's one of the funniest scenes so
he put it back
yeah they glued it back on but he
wouldn't tell him where he'd hidden it
first it's not funny
he's there hopping around on one leg so
I think this isn't funny it's one of the
best scenes in in the Orville it's just
he I don't think he could have it only
he could have pulled it off I thought it
was just perfect yeah
um so I mean this is the generic
question it's a boring question but what
made you want to get into the acting
career oh is it the big was it the girls
it was the girls no you know I think it
was um I lived in a very very small town
up in Northern Canada so I'm like
19 I guess I I was thinking of what I
was gonna do in high school and I just
always thought I like being I like the
acting and then I I kind of got
hooked on it
from watching um
Welcome Back Cotter of all shows you
know do you remember that show I don't
think we got that over here I don't
think that was one it was a show um with
um oh gosh what's his name now come on
uh he'll come to me anyway it was a
story about a group of kids in high
school in New York and they were all
Misfits
and um
oh gosh Come on Mary John Travolta
thanks that my wife popped in and gave
me the ticket watching John Travolta in
Welcome Back Cotter was wearing a cut I
want to do that that's what I want to do
I want to be an actor and I've never
been an actor I've never done anything
of a hockey player all my life so uh
yeah I ended up
applying to a couple theater school
stuff I got in but I don't know how I
got in and then I met somebody else
there who's ahead of another theater
program in Toronto and uh
I wish I had happened to apply for but
never auditioned for and I
I was in bamf School of Fine Arts at the
time and summer program and I met him
and he said well you can audition from
here if you want so I did and I got in
and I left for Toronto and that was that
I haven't been doing it ever since
that's amazing I suppose you have to end
up in Vancouver
you have to end up in Vancouver at some
point yeah geez I was in Toronto then I
went to Chicago and then because I was
on tour with Stratford and we went
through Chicago and I liked it so I went
back there got an aged there but there
was a writer's drink writer strike kit
so I basically get on to strike
sometimes really you're doing it again
now so that was a long one that was over
a year
oh I don't remember that one yeah I know
it was just It Was 1980
seven I think I think 85 or 87 86
something like that so I kind of ran out
of money you know and I was doing
landscaping jobs and whatever else I
could do and then I went back to Toronto
and then uh from there I came to
Vancouver and then from Vancouver went
to Los Angeles and then Los Angeles I
came back
so
now I'm here I mean yeah so I just work
in Social care your job's more
interesting
um
so all right well we have to mention
Stargate as you said your industry one
and then later on you were in Stargate
Atlantis but you played Ferretti in the
first round and you you had one of the
best scenes in the children of God I
have to say with Sam Carter comes in and
she sits down and she and her and her
knee you'll have a bit of a uh I don't
like do you think it's like I don't like
women think and anything no I'm cool
with women scientists I don't like and
and you didn't you were in one of the
best things um I've actually cut that
scene and put it in a few of my videos
over the years oh really wow you know
I'm probably gonna I'm probably gonna
play it again now
um what do you remember though from
because obviously that's that's when we
got sg1 on the small screen what do you
want to remember from making that what
did I remember um well there's a lot of
talk about it that's for sure and um you
know meeting everybody and it was the
pilot and Mario as a party was directing
it and it was a lot of excitement about
it I remember that and and uh
I've got him Don Davis was there Don was
a friend of mine so I knew a couple of
guys you know I'd uh worked with Don a
few times I did a I did actually a
really cool project with Don called The
Monkey House which is uh Kurt Vonnegut
wrote the short story and uh we did a a
movie or a hour special of it I don't
remember what channel it was what who
did it somebody I can't remember tell
you truth but um that was a fun show and
Kurt Vonnegut came to the set
which was crazy yeah it was nuts he came
and he talked to us about the characters
and seen them come to life and
everything that was a big current Bonnet
fan at the time and that was really cool
to meet him and stuff well Thomas Davis
is a one of the most popular characters
within Stargate honestly it was a great
great guy man a really wonderful person
yeah I mean there's so many episodes in
that that he drove that you know he
really was missed it was a very nice
thing that they actually named Starship
the BC 304 in later episodes they called
it the Hammond
um
which was a nice thing for them to do
um was there a lot of so you've
mentioned there's a lot of excitement
about the sg1 was there there was there
a feeling that this was something
yeah I was surprised they didn't really
do much with Ferretti
with like I didn't I was surprising he
didn't have he wasn't around more I
never really understood I found out why
he wasn't around one but uh yeah it was
fun I enjoyed doing it you know and I
enjoyed going back and but then uh
yeah it just and then I ended up on the
other one uh yeah so it was fun though I
remember uh there was a lot of
excitement around it when it started in
the cast and everything
I did mention to Brad Wright I I tweaked
Broadway occasionally I did mention that
um we were having you on and I did sort
of say if there's anything you want me
to ask him and you're like I can't think
of anything which isn't surprising but
he did say to say hello oh hello so um
so yeah and I know you're watching my
videos because occasionally he corrects
me
yeah because no actually Jamie you're
incorrect this is about but I'm like
okay sorry there's a lot of episodes
holy man and I've worked since with just
about
uh well a lot of the actors from the
show I keep working Michael Shanks and I
we did uh Smallville
all right we did the Justice League
character in Smallville was actually
quite a big character wasn't it yeah
yeah I think actually I was the first
According to some fans I don't know I
don't I'm not I don't check up on this
stuff I just hear about it but
accordingly I was the first guy to ever
play Dr Fate outside of animation
yeah
um you mentioned this to me before and I
checked you were ah because I look into
these things but that and obviously so
you and James Bond next really okay I
mean you and Mr Bronson yeah I don't see
that happening yeah hey we need a new
James Bond yeah
why not have a Canadian yeah right
um but yeah um I can't remember I don't
remember Michael Jackson's Smallville
but I think he played uh Hawkman I
believe he's a character so it would
have been adjusted it was kind of like
we had a really nice relationship he
kind of takes care of my um my uh Alter
Ego guy when I'm not doctor's faith I
forget the character's name now but uh
he's got uh he's got schizophren almost
schizophrenia like he's a helmet helmet
drives him man right so when he takes
the helmet off he's all in Michael's
kind of like a surrogate father to him
in a way way we had a nice relationship
with that was fun to do okay when we
look back and I mean I think one of the
things the fans like about sg1 that it
did seem that it was that there was a
bit of a family that everyone seemed to
get on
um I know Michael Jackson left sg1 for a
little while and he said it was just
mainly because he felt the character
wasn't really going anywhere but very
quickly realized and came back what was
your sense about how because you came in
very early on
I was in the pilot I don't think they
knew exactly where they were gonna go
with all the characters at that point I
think they did with probably you know
the main guys we were like supposed to
be reoccurring there was another guy on
there who was kind of a major
what's his name
I haven't seen him in about 25 years
that's why I can't remember probably
haven't seen him much since then because
he got out of the business but he was a
major and he was kind of the right-hand
man of Dawn's character
he left too because he wasn't gonna he
didn't he wasn't gonna get used much you
know
so nobody I don't think I knew exactly
where they were going with it at that
time yeah that's normal with the pilot
though isn't it yeah yeah they shake
things off back to the party absolutely
and snow piercer I did the TV series
snow piercer I had a kind of uh
reoccurring in it I played tunnelman
Jakes in it yeah and uh they had all
kinds of stuff with the pilot I think
they shot one first and then redid it
they redid the whole pilot change some
characters around gave parts to other
people some people came some people went
you know that was a fun show too I liked
I liked the cast and crew of that show
was really a lot of fun
I actually think they should do pilots
more often I don't I think in a lot of
streaming Series today they don't they
don't really do pilots anymore they just
sort of do 10 episodes yeah I don't
think that you kind of stuck with a few
mistakes then though if there's anything
that's not quite right yeah and then you
kind of have to weed them out as they go
along a little bit right all right
then without the pilot you you can't you
can't really tell what the chemistry is
going to be like right I think I know
Brad Wright talks a lot about that he
talks about how they he watches the
characters
and he sort of he studies them and then
tries to bring some of that character
from the actors actually into what he
does yeah yeah that makes sense
some people really hit off and some
people jump some people have nice
relationships some don't you know
I think if you can bring as much of that
through so that you're acting a bit less
yeah that may be quite important yeah
well for sure yeah
but um you then came back from Michael
in SGS before you were replaced
now um I forget his name but he was he
played Tripp in Star Trek Enterprise and
he played the human version of Michael
but you were The Wraith version yeah so
at this point were you just basically
getting every part that they could dump
as much makeup on you as humanly
possible
they called me in for that kind of out
of the blue I think I think what was
supposed to happen was he was supposed
to do both parts but he couldn't end up
doing The Wraith part
I think his wife was having a baby or
something like that yeah and so they
called me and said hey would you do this
and I said sure
but I didn't know what was all going on
I kind of came in as like a shooting uh
shooting from the hip kind of run you
know just
yeah
yeah a gun for hire kind of guy on that
one so yeah it was fun though I enjoyed
it I just it was weird for me because I
just come through a I just had a surgery
on my neck I had a bone uh a Fusion on
my neck
yeah I had been doing a lot of
grappling and stuff at the time and I
kind of just wore it out you know just
from popping and all that stuff anyway
so I had a thing on my neck right I had
to put a titanium little titanium plate
and a bone graft in my neck now it was
coming out of I just had it done a
little while it was just in recovery and
that gate offered me the part so it was
the first thing I'd come back and I was
like really oh they're like really stiff
they were great they were every time
they were cut they'd give me a chair and
I'd sit down I'm like you know because
it was it was uh kind of work for the
characters in it because they were not
exactly it was they were quite stiff
anyway they were not exactly sort of
dancers were they the race so um I think
that's fair enough I did a show one time
called I still Dream of Jeannie way long
time ago remember a dream of jeans yeah
well they did one I was just just out of
theater School me and Jason show me we
played these two guys Tweedy and
Tweedledum in the show and we kidnapped
these kid and so it was a lot of fun but
um just before I was about to shoot the
show I broke my foot
like two weeks before so I I did
everything and I was like what am I
gonna do tell them guys they're gonna
fire me in so I called them up and they
said no no we'll just we'll just get
your canes what kind of King you know
and so I can't ride this cane and it
worked out it was brilliant it worked
out great and everybody thought that's
the choice of the foot the foot thing
was a great choice well done very clever
yeah
clever at all it was just I broke my
foot yeah oh well you get a lot of those
happy accidents yeah we see that I like
this target
um I remember one that Michael Shanks
had to have his appendix actually just
wrote it in oh yeah he had his appendix
there that helps you know somebody was
pregnant no I'll put it in the show yeah
why not
um it's better than when they try to
hide a pregnancy and all of a sudden
they'll start wearing a scarf or
something and they'll just do shots
where they sat down a lot everything's
above that I think she's pregnant yeah
um so um was SGA
because obviously it was quite a
different team on there did it feel
different when you were on Stargate
Atlantis rather than sg1 or was it just
a job and
it didn't feel that different you know I
mean the thing is that you know when you
you get to work on a show for a long
time you get to know everybody really
well so uh
when I went because I started the pilot
on sd1 I still I felt like pretty much I
came in at the beginning but then I
wasn't on it for a lot then I came back
for an episode and you know it's still
and that felt like oh going home like
that was it because that other one
wasn't I wasn't wasn't my show right I
was like yes just doing a guest star or
a spot right and sometimes that that's
that's one of the tougher gigs when you
go to a series is when you're it's great
if you're going and doing the guest star
but if you only have a couple days it's
it's gonna be tough it's one of the
harder things to do us because you don't
you're just in there and you're not
they'll feel everybody's Vibe you don't
know everybody's just coming in do your
bit and go right but but it was fun yeah
I imagine that's like it really say my
job I have to flip from place to place
and I imagine this sort of thing that if
you go into a job you don't it's just
silly little things like well you don't
know everybody but you don't know where
the coffee machine is and you don't know
where yeah you just gonna feel a bit
awkward and does that make your job must
make your job really hard though because
then obviously you've got to relax and
try to
yeah it is yeah I mean a lot of shows
will make you feel really good you know
and just other shows they don't make you
feel good at all you feel like an alien
in there and you're like I just want to
give this and get the hell out of here
you have those too right but um uh I
just did a show a little spot on
something about something about Todd do
you hear do you guys have that over
there yeah we've got that everything and
they were great like going into that one
and doing my bit they were fantastic all
the actors were great to you and all the
stuff like that when that's happened
when they do that it's fantastic I had
one a little while ago with another show
and it was opposite of that
it was awful it was it's just not a fun
experience you know
yeah what do you think cause is that
though is it like the director down or
is it you know well what do you think
sometimes well it's I think what happens
with that is that when they
some shows they treat you like a day
player and some controls they teach and
you might be doing the same thing and
they treat you like an actor and that's
the difference really you know a little
bit of respect something or a little bit
of that a little bit of that some don't
some do you know and then don't you but
that's part of the gigs it's part of
being an actor again I suppose like
normal jobs your job isn't normal but a
normal job
um if there's pressure and it only takes
one or two people sometimes if there's
if there's a stress it can affect the
whole vibe of the place
I don't think one person sometimes yeah
and you walk in an eggshell sort of
thing yeah
um
well you are probably in the Sci-Fi
world at least most famous for your part
on Andromeda yeah the Five Seasons I
think three I think three oh three three
seasons only three I did some spots and
stuff here and there yeah that was um
that was probably like my biggest sci-fi
gig for sure yeah well you played ref
bam yeah today the least was an
interesting character yeah he was it was
a fun character I mean the species was
Whoever thought that was something wrong
with them yeah how much of it do you
remember though
yeah I did a lot of work on kind of that
the tough part was molding that
Killer Instinct stuff into somebody
who's spiritual right because that was
the thing was he was at odds with
himself all the time he was always
trying to
uh do what was good and what was right
but fighting his instincts to you know
maim and eat
so that was quite a bit of fun so we
came up with an idea that the whole
um
Buddhist philosophy with him right like
uh so I I did a lot I had done a lot of
research on that stuff and I I think I
brought a lot of things to it like and
if I wanted things they would uh they
were definitely uh go yeah that's a
great idea let's do that so like I
wanted a meditation stool in my room and
I wanted a I wanted a a staff as a tool
to fight with as well because that was a
Buddhist weapon right
and uh yeah so we came up with all these
kind of things kind of they were very
Cooperative as far as ideas that you had
when it came to that stuff like you said
earlier they kind of took what I had as
well and they were like they watch you
for a while and then they start you know
going hey let's let's go this way do you
know what I mean they they yeah they
kind of worked around you they start to
become
you know aware of what you're doing and
and incorporated into the show and stuff
that's gotta be the best way to do
something like that because then it
becomes part of you doesn't it it's like
yeah I mean yeah yeah
and so uh yeah and also the fighting
style because there was so much makeup
like sure yeah you look like it's like a
man 11 pieces on the face and the
headpiece and teeth and it was so much
stuff that you know to get somebody in
there to stunt you and people didn't
like it like nobody ever wanted to do it
nobody wanted to get the stunt stuff on
uh we had one guy who I did a fall of
building and stuff they do those kind of
things but they didn't really want to
get in so I just did my own fighting all
the fighting games me doing it and I
worked with a guy who was a Wing Chun
guy we thought oh that that's great
we'll do a lot of Wing Chun hand stuff
because I had all these flaws right so
we had to love that ripping I remember
yeah
that kind of style it was kind of where
we're going man that was fun yeah did
you ever get hurt doing that yeah a
couple times I got caught on fire once
well that's a story
yeah the tear and I the character of
tear we're in an episode of the I think
it's a Rico meru gets caught on fire I
can't remember I think that's the one
the ship and we've got those things you
know we're putting out the fire and I
have a long orange capy Roby thing right
and so they had butane or whatever they
were using coming out of jet so they can
control it and turn it down and stuff
so I was
doing my thing and Escape I guess went
through the
fire and got caught on fire well I went
in first suit man you know I was on the
first suit so uh I don't know if it was
fire retardant or not I could have gone
up like very good but I didn't uh and
the character tier he goes you're on
fire on fire but I keep turning he goes
fire I think it's a compliment I'm with
me can I just go off and roll because we
were on a great so so that wouldn't have
done anything wouldn't have done any
good I don't think so anyway I think
somebody grabbed it put it out whatever
just it's an end caught fire it was
funny
like we can do that again we should use
that and they're like no we shouldn't
use that we're not going to use that no
but it'll make a great story at some
point yeah
i i i i i adored Andromeda Andromeda was
one of those TV shows for me that it was
um some people call it the Star Trek's
poor cousin or something like that yeah
but I think I I liked that about it
there's a TV show that I adore it's my
favorite show ever it's called Firefly
oh I like that too yeah and and it had a
similar sort of vibe to it that it was
sort of like it didn't take itself too
seriously the big blue guy right with
the thing the blue guy with things on
Firefly didn't have a big alien guy
no I know you're thinking about no I'm
that's not um Firefly they Firefly was
Nathan Fillion you're thinking about
Farscape fires I think you'll think
about Farscape I went with the actual
player into the blue guy to New Zealand
and Australia for a car yeah the
convention when we first started out he
was right he brought us two there him
his show and myself uh two kind of alien
dudes right we had so much fun it was
nice I liked him I would say that's a
similar sort of thing yeah that's just
far escapes a similar sort of thing as
well that it's new it knew what it was
sort of thing yeah yeah I love that show
as well I love the Jim Henson stuff in
Farscape and um because they had all the
puppets and things yeah but obviously
Ben Browder then left and um Claudia
Black then left Farscape and joined um
sg1 towards the end for the last two
seasons
give it give it a look at some point
basically Claudia Black just wears
leather outfits for two seasons oh nice
it's it's worth it's worth it
is great in it as well there's a joke
because obviously Ben Browder and
Michael Jackson don't you ever notice
they kind of look similar
so there's a scene where they sort of
they stood next to each other and
Claudia Black comes down and goes she's
cracking jokes yeah I remember that now
that they did yeah I do yeah
this is an interesting Planet but it
must have quite a shallow gene pool
but they look so similar
um but um yeah I mean I I did love
Andromeda
um I I think I'm not going to ask you
about this but I do actually follow
um uh Kevin sawberg on Twitter
very interesting opinions
um so here it is he's very conservative
so I mean yeah was he interesting to
work with
well I liked him I I mean I I got along
well with him and he was uh yeah he was
easy to work with and great guy and yeah
um there was not as far as I knew or
anything uh just had a lot of political
stuff I stay away from all that stuff on
sets anyway
it's better I think for me anyway just I
don't get involved in that kind of thing
I have opinions about politics or
religion or anything like that it's not
about the show
I don't really get too involved you know
and and people get a bit more Angry as
they get older sometimes so maybe in a
long time and two it's just I mean
whatever his spiritual beliefs and stuff
are I mean that's his his bag I mean I
think in this day and age with social
media can be very good for some things
and it can be very
dangerous than other things so I think
you have to kind of and especially with
actors like
you know uh I have younger actors that I
know who are coming up and doing really
well and stuff like that and and they're
all over the social media yeah
I'm not and they keep telling me you
know you got to get involved and I just
I go wow it's just a lot of stuff to do
I'm just it's like you got a post you
got to do this you gotta you gotta
understand the platforms you got to know
who's watching what all that stuff and
I'm just like wow you know I mean if
you're Russell Crowe you have somebody
doing it for you I think right I think a
lot of them
yeah that's another person that you have
on your
I know
that's happened a few times overlap the
timelines yeah so much doing do inside
doing this channel you have to be
involved in social media and you've got
to have a thick skin yeah that's partly
to it I'm not I don't
really like I'm not on Facebook
I'm not on those things I'm kind of on
Instagram but I don't really use it but
I like to
scroll through and see what people are
doing once in a while you know yeah
uh but I just I don't know I never
really got into it
you know I I I just do it for the
channel now yeah because I got I used to
have a channel doing like talking about
Mysteries and conspiracies I love a good
story that's my thing I love stories
yeah and so I always talk about these
stories but I would then tear them apart
sort of things say well look this
probably isn't true but unfortunately
I've got a lot of people and getting
very angry at me calling me [__] and
stuff but one of them actually then
started to try to message my wife oh and
it was that point I went no okay we've
got to stop doing this now so I shut it
all down uh yeah
um how much do you think movie and TV
has sort of changed though during your
career because I mean you've worked in
this like you said for 40 years yeah
social media and stuff today
so different you know I don't sound like
an old guy but well I can't I'm old guy
but uh you know
they don't have dailies anymore you just
watch it right there I when I was doing
Smallville they would they were editing
it as they go you want to see the scene
I was like we just shot it they go yeah
yeah we've got to kind of rough cut
you know it's insane to me because you
know you used to have to watch dailies
one time I did um
a thing called um
what's it called Poltergeist do you
remember that series
I had a great part in that I really had
a lot of fun I played this guy who was a
ex-seal commander and I let's go into a
new realm to find my guys I eat spiders
eat special spiders that have this Venom
that you know I go transcend into a
different realm kind of thing you know
those you know how they work yeah
uh what was I do oh and so we um we shot
him I had a really really emotional
scene with Martin Cummins and stuff and
we chopped the whole thing and that film
with the close-ups these close-ups
got messed up it like got somebody
opened it or whatever and it got ruined
oh okay yeah so I came in the next day
and it was um like we had shot all day
the scenes and stuff and so I came in
the next day and they went Brent we got
to reshoot all your close-ups just you
and they had built a little thing on the
side that were just where the so they
could see the trees behind me I was like
I thought they were kidding right I
thought you're joking right I got to do
just my close-ups on the emotional stuff
right they said yeah we lost all the
ecu's or extreme close-ups or they're
called and I was like wow okay so we did
it I just said okay we shot all just the
close-ups of the scene right and it
worked out fine it was great but it's
like you don't really have I don't think
you have that problem anymore I mean
so many things are backed up if that one
goes that one goes you know there's so
much you have that and you can see it
like we never had monitors so you never
knew what you were gonna what you really
were doing you didn't really what was
going on
you're gonna kind of guessed it right
he's like the director knew what he was
doing
and then they got monitors and I was
like wow that was the coolest thing in
the Earth
yeah so you can actually see what's
happening in real time
yeah what's that and react a bit more I
imagine then yeah you can go back into
the monitor if you want and watch it we
can watch some playback okay let's try
that or let's try it whatever you want
to do or I'm not a big playback Watcher
either I leave that to the director
sometimes
because I don't like to see myself like
doing it some people love it
do you think it's changed in a positive
way though is the last thing I mean
because streaming has probably been the
biggest
thing yeah well
it's uh it's I don't know if it's both
good it has good things it has bad
things right I mean get a lot of product
out there you get to see a lot of stuff
um
sometimes the quality is poor because of
it I think that the quality over
quantity yeah
but there's sometimes too it's even just
watching there's so much stuff to watch
you know
and um
I don't know it's also too it's
interesting who's going to control
everything now right there's so many
that's what's this all this writer
strike is about really she's controlling
all the product and you know as an actor
if you're on residuals they play all
over the place you don't know where
they're all playing you don't know if
you're getting paid or not you know
there's all those kind of things that
come with it yeah and yeah I have an
active friend who does a lot of
voiceovers for adverts and things and he
actually said he um about two three
years ago he suddenly got a check for 50
Grand and he's this is the biggest check
he's ever had in his life he's not he's
not famous for anything he just does
voiceover stuff right and it was just
because they'd accidentally forgotten to
pay him for this one job and he didn't
he didn't even know she's got all these
residuals and we're so so sorry it's
like a 50 Grand secondary nice well they
have people in the union who follow that
right and do that where they're playing
and if they're not playing and stuff
like that you know I I remember saying
to me afterwards because what else have
they forgotten I can't please play my
mortgage what else
am I not getting I don't know that is
the big problem with the writers because
because I know like Netflix and people
are this they don't like releasing the
numbers they don't like telling what the
residuals are actually like no so
I can understand that I I said it on one
of my channels because if I was in my
job and I got like told right next week
you're getting a 50 Quid bonus but the
week after you're only getting 20 I'd be
like why yeah and I'd want to know you
know so I can understand that writers
and actors and everybody really in the
industry yeah and some again some people
are really good at it and some actors
are just not good about it they're just
I just want to act you know just do this
this there's an artist temperament in a
lot you know
but I think too A lot of people are
becoming more Savvy with all that stuff
as well as actors you know they never
taught us any of that stuff when I was
in go it was just theater school never
taught you any of that how to sell your
stuff or any you know none of that sort
of thing
they do that now just I teach at a
school on occasion and they have courses
where they help they have girl comes in
and say okay
here's what you should do with your
money or whatever you're doing or you
should do this so here's some helpful
hints and stuff
I never we never any of that probably so
many actors have been burned over the
years I mean I've got a little bit cage
and people like that they're just robbed
blind sure because yeah and a lot of
actors too don't have that um business
savvy some do some are great at it you
know
some just leave it up to their agent or
their lawyers or the managers whatever
and they give us the wrong person yeah
it's just the wrong person they're only
screwed I know it's happened it's
happened in sports and stuff over the
years as well
when you get autistic people sometimes
they just care about the craft well
that's it right and two yeah and uh yeah
it's interesting
so I mean
so what are you doing there what sort of
projects have you or whatever
yeah I'm in Vancouver right now that's
where I live and so you take kind of
what's coming down the pike right so
whatever shows they're working on that
that are going I just uh
um did a few episodes a little while ago
of Chesapeake Shores it's a show that
just stopped now but um it was uh
I worked with Treat Williams just like
six months ago who passed recently in a
motorcycle accident he was a really
wonderful guy man and that was a great
show to work on great cast great crew
just fun they took you in in a heartbeat
oh you're new ones who come on in it was
like great you know I had some friend a
couple friends on the show and I met
tree and he was really great and uh so
that was a fun one
um
um I did and I'm doing some Hallmark
stuff as well and doing whatever comes
up really right now I'm working on a
thing um
uh I think I can say this it's called
the murder on murders it's about a guy
who uh real life story about a guy who
killed his wife and his son or
I was accused of that I think he's gone
to prison so I can probably say he hello
that's the word I'm looking for that's
the protector we're a legend
so I'm doing that and I'm playing his uh
his cousin uh and that I'm having a fun
time for that from South Carolina cool
yeah and I got accepted coming out and
little things I did you know yeah well
there's going to be a lot of work in
Vancouver at the moment because
um The Bridge Studio is having a massive
revamp apparently or are they
um yeah
um it's uh uh oh I forget what it's
called them BSM or BMS or something
they've partnered with the guys that own
The Bridge Studio and they're building
six different stages there apparently
and
somebody else has just bought the
Vancouver film uh Studios wow yeah I
know a lot of what's going on here well
because I'm following we're going on
with Stargate yeah um obviously I I
follow it religiously and we think that
they're gonna do another season of
sterigator they're getting all the
regular gays back or are they getting
new people yeah so the rumors are that
it will be a Revival of sg1 so it'll be
that style of showing that sort of
format it looks like they're gonna get a
movie as well nice very exciting
um and it does look like yeah we're
going to be at least getting Amanda tap
in uh Michael Shanks and maybe Richard
Dean Anderson for cameo in the first few
things so the the rumor is it'll be like
General Samantha Carter right and
Michael Shanks might be the sort of like
the civilian leader of the FCC now nice
or something well that's what I say if
you actually you could come back would
you come back as Ferretti or Michael
Freddy yeah I thought that was easy yeah
and you could though couldn't you could
just be that would be so easy for you to
just appear so I'll mention it yeah Merc
somewhere
yeah let's see how cool would that be
yeah yeah
oh that's a Black Ops
I've already taken it dark
but yeah but there is a big room
actually that it might be filmed at
Vancouver oh so that might go home
that'd be good for it yeah yeah so there
you go and you're local so that's right
we'll immediately start a campaign to
get you to get you back on this bring
back for ready we're ready wherever he
went I don't know where he went
one of the other teams that we never saw
so what happened or maybe after
Kowalski's mate died maybe he um yeah
maybe he maybe broken I don't know maybe
we should find out it's one of the big
questions we need answering what's Chris
doing these days
um there's a big rumor that he's going
to be doing the new
um Warhammer series oh really well he
does the voice for um the cartoon no God
of War so not Warhammer that's um so the
God of War series he does the voice
um and they body show for the game uh
god of war and there's a theories Amazon
bought a series and there's a there's a
big room that Chris judge is going to be
doing that nice so
um fingers crossed that's what that's
what the fans want there's been a big
campaign to try and get him yeah
so I mean that would be very very cool
um yeah it's whether it happens or not
because obviously in the woke culture
that we've got at the moment
some there's been some gender swapping
in TV shows and things like that and
people have started to get a bit angry
about it so the God of War character is
a white Nordic character so having
Christopher George
but the thing is because he played as
the voice and it's so popular in the
game
the fans are desperate for him to do it
so that kind of does take away the
bigots wind out of the sails a little
bit yeah
um but um but you know hey we're gonna
have a Canadian James Bond
why not Christopher Judge
the God of War character though yeah
to have a Canadian James Bond you got to
be British right yeah well we had a
Scottish one so why not
yeah yeah and Brent thank you so so much
for your time it's really been an
absolute blast I promise I would keep it
under an hour for you so
um and I've and I've managed to do it
for you you had to clear some of the
cobwebs out there it's been a while
since I talked about this stuff so yeah
I mean we'd love to get you back at some
point if you if ever you've got time um
I'd love actually if the guy's watching
this video if you've got any questions
for Brent and you want to stick him in
the comments I'll I'll keep track and if
we can get Brent back we will ask them
here because I'm an idiot I can never
think of anything to ask you I mean
afterwards I'll think of loads and lots
of stuff like I go for a job interview
another way home and go oh I should have
said that but no seriously Brent thank
you so so much and um nice being here I
know everyone's gonna go crazy so thank
you thank